what's the last thing you remember Danny
you said we had to route the reason you
survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know how mutants are would anyone
like to shared their first time brain I
was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control
so I just started panicking people got
hurt
Roberto my girlfriend
Liliana I killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better
I suppose something
I don't think she wanted me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes her live through it until it
kills you
[Music]
he's there we can get out of this
together
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my breakdown of the New Mutants
trailer remember when this was a movie
that was coming out into theatres that
we could watch so I'll explain what's
going on with the history of the movie
is all this new footage we have a pretty
good idea for what's going on with the
movie so if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
easter-egg videos we're also doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on
the video obviously this is now
technically a Marvel film since Marvel
owns all the Fox characters originally
it was planned to be within the x-men
universe of films when they first
started making the movie a couple years
ago originally they were gonna have a
post-credits scene with Jon Hamm
appearing as a version of mr. sinister
and it was gonna sort of be a follow-up
to that x-men apocalypse post-credit
scene with essex Corp and Wolverine mr.
Sinister's people showing up to steal
Wolverines blood Weapon X presumably for
some genetics testing because genetic
engineering is one of his big things in
the comics but mr. sinister is not the
main villain of the new mutants movie
it's actually demon bear from the comics
they even shown towards the end of the
trailer here so I'll try to explain
what's going on because the new mutants
movie is meant to be a sort of rubber
reality horror film according to Josh
Boone the director and that's a genre of
film where people don't know whether or
not their reality really is real like
Total Recall or The Truman Show or The
Matrix
you see Illyana Rasputin magics
character talking to Danny moon star
when she's trying to push through that
barrier like no no no we're definitely
trapped here so it sounds like this
mental institute is really just a mental
projection and they're all trapped in
this shared psychic reality by demon
bear who's trying to consume them but
this version of the trailer is much more
complete and gives you a little bit more
to the idea of this story than the last
big trailer so you just go down the list
here this person here that's playing the
nurse ratchet character thinking about
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest because
this is technically supposed to be a
mental institution that they're in this
is Celia Reyes she is an x-men character
who has the ability to generate a
protective bio field around herself
technically she's a good character in
the comics but if demon bear really is
going to be the main villain of the film
demon bear is capable of possessing
people and consuming their souls that's
one of his main things so he could be
possessing
in keeping them trapped in this fake
reality part of the reason why I think
the demon bear is so important to this
is because the first character that you
talked to the first member of the New
Mutants team is Danny Moonstar in demon
bears critical to her origin story in
the comics she's the first person you go
to in the trailer although technically
it's an ensemble film so they're all
meant to be main characters all the
different types of visions that you see
them get when they're trapped in this
place or them reliving some of their
origin stories some aspects of it
twisted in a really horrifying way one
of the big things about demon bear is
the feeds off of negative emotions so
he's probably just trying to freak them
out as much as possible so that he can
feed on them Mirage in the comics is a
Native American mutant who just has the
power to create illusions drawn from the
fears and desires of people's minds then
they go to Maisie Williams character
she's playing Rayne Sinclair aka
Wolfsbane she's playing a Scottish
mutant who in this course of the film is
struggling to reconcile her religious
beliefs with her power to turn into a
wolf so when they go to each of the
different characters they give you one
of their visions that they're
experiencing in this psychic place and
she's in this church because she's
supposed to be a really religious person
but she's also in the process of turning
into a werewolf make all the game of
thrones direwolf jokes you want I
believe this was actually filmed around
the time that they were doing Game of
Thrones Season seven that's how long ago
this movie was filmed then we go to
Charlie Hedon you probably remember him
from stranger things he's playing Sam
Guthrie aka cannonball he's a mutant who
can propel himself into the air and is
invulnerable while he's doing so he
starts using his power a little bit
later in the trailer with sunspot - then
you go to Roberto de Costa aka sunspot
he's a Brazilian mutant with the ability
to manipulate solar energy this is what
he looks like when he fully activates
his powers I'm actually glad that they
went with a little more comic book II
approach to their powers it wasn't
really clear from the last trailer if
they were gonna do that then you're all
probably familiar with on a tail or
joy's character Illyana Rasputin aka
magic because she's the younger sister
of Colossus now because we have a
colossus in the Deadpool movies but we
also have a separate version of Colossus
in the mainstream x-men films you can
pick which version of Colossus you think
would be her older brother
but since Deadpool's version seems to be
the main version now we'll assume that
it's him she has all kinds of crazy
magic
get it powers in the comics you see
pretty much all them on display during
the trailer like she has her psionic
magical armor she's the psychic soul
blade that you see and she can open
interdimensional portals that you see
her dropping through later in the
trailer when they're fighting the giant
psychic version of demon bear I don't
know who's playing the demon bear
character if he really is going to be
the main villain but originally like I
said there was gonna be that Jon Hamm
mr. sinister post-credits scene it was
recorded that at some point during the
production process they changed that
scene in the new post-credit scene was
gonna be Antonio Banderas playing an
unnamed villain so Antonio Banderas
himself could be playing the demon bear
character for the most part all the
stuff you see all the different scenes
are them reliving versions of their
origin story in really tragic ways
because one of the themes up a lot of
the x-men films is that when their
powers manifest they wind up hurting a
whole bunch of people on accident
without meaning to society winds up
demonizing them for it and they either
they're helped by the x-men and
Professor X or they're found by some
villain group and taken in way before
the Fox Disney buyout deal there were
plans to do a trilogy of New Mutants
films I believe the original plans were
for the Hellfire Club to become one of
the main villains for this New Mutants
team-up because you have Roberto de
castas father who is attached to the
Hellfire Club in the comics for the most
part it seems like the plot of the movie
is meant to be pretty simple they all
find themselves in this mental institute
because they're mutants they meet each
other they get to know each other a
little bit better then eventually as
[ __ ] goes off the rails they start to
notice the reality crumbling around
themselves like you see this door sort
of disappear like oh this isn't real
we're not in a real place this is some
psychic projection someone's trapping us
here why are they trapping us here and
then slowly learn about what's going on
with demon bear I know a lot of you have
questions about how this fits in with
the Marvel movies because technically
this is part of Marvel Marvel phase 4
now even though it was done at Fox Way
before the deal was ever done so what
kind of exists in its own little bubble
of continuity I don't know that there
are plans to bring these versions of the
characters into the mainstream MCU
anytime soon I think they're just gonna
wait and see how the movie does but it
is meant to be a legit horror film Kevin
Feige watched it didn't make them change
anything originally when the film was
still just at Fox they were gonna make
him do a bunch of refuse to water it
down and make it less of a
film so we think it bodes really well
for the movie that Kevin Feige saw it
and said no no no this version is great
do it horror it's awesome release it
like this no changes and I think this
movie is actually gonna be a good test
case for how the MCU is gonna treat the
r-rated Deadpool solo films sort of off
in their own little bubble of continuity
but loosely attached to the MCU through
references but something to remember is
that this movie was made a couple years
ago before the Fox Disney deal so it
wasn't designed to be part of the MCU
originally where as Deadpool 3 is now
being worked on the writing the script
that will be designed with the MCU in
mind but everyone let me know in the
comments was your favorite moment from
the trailer and what do you want them to
do with these characters after this film
if it's successful do you want to see
some of them pop up in an MCU film at
some point everyone click here to learn
what's going on with Quicksilver in
Doctor Strange 2 in the 1 division
series and click here to learn why
Marvel can finally make a new Hulk solo
movie again thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome Happy
New Year
[Music]